welcome to this video this is me playing
white ear five-minute yyh something Oh
China maybe so maybe I can start a
string now or six wins that would be
cool after ending this year it's of six
losses wow it takes ages him played him
once before and won the game let's try
that I recently looked at this a little
bit not in much detail but interesting
c5 I really I have forgotten of the
finer points i have to admit and i
usually don't fare well in those
scenarios i tend to get checkmated quite
a bit but okay I want to play a variety
of openings and not the same thing all
over again so what about this here night
to be five attacking d6 this an idea
night c7 also in
okay it takes it it's a very uncommon
way of handling is because the light
squared Bishop is usually a very
important piece to force through them
the g4 push in the first place here g4
looks very difficult to achieve if not
impossible okay rook c6 he's got 97 so
maybe Roxy to Roxy once the simpler
option yeah I'm controlling the C file
him an endgame is just excellent for
white it's bishop where are you going
yeah let's do this this should basically
force the Queen trade or queen d 8 but
Queen d8 what what kind of move is that
yeah any endgame is great because i have
many weaknesses to attack d 6 a-6 got
two bishops and this Bishop one g7 is
bad night h4 was a bit strange I mean he
never checked mates now hit with us bad
pieces I don't don't think that happens
and it won't happen to check here
because I winning this rook okay it's
just a rook let's continue yeah the
black there's a the key point here is
that he I don't really know the precise
move orders but this is probably
something that is kind of okay I mean
probably maybe not the best ever or
whatever but it seems okay but I'm not
really sure here I think he should avoid
um Bishop takes be five after that I
think white is considerably better
because it's difficult to force through
G form the compounds to play g4
immediately that looks more like it like
this this and Queen B 6 that looks
interesting
setting up possible ideas like that very
sharp position also Knight takes e4 is
even the more interesting option by very
unclear after this blacks position is
very very dubious strategically here
okay I'm glad to go back to me because
I'm looking at this crucial breakthrough
square 27km b3 b5 here I think he a bite
is basically winning strategically I
mean given that I avoid any any big
blunders white should win it's too much
Bishop air light squares weaknesses them
I have the C file NTM he has to allow
the Queen trade but to illustrate how
bad this is on the compass on + 2.5 for
white so it already sees the size of
material against okay blending the rook
rook didn't help but yeah it's it's
already very problematic now the night
is also offside on edge for he's never
going to manage to flow I'm just yeah
I'm protecting this like a million times
so that was a good quick quick win and
start over run there to win sit okay
thanks for watching guys